this game is basically just one long
dirty computer engine line
white stuff lays a very strong and
creative engine creates a magical attack
against igel offering multiple piece
sacrifices for long-term compensation in
fact igel doesn't understand it's losing
until way too late and even thinks that
it's winning at some points when it is
probably losing the game opens here with
b3 a modern favorite of many and now e5
bishop b2 knight c6 e3 and d5
now those of you not that familiar with
computer chess games might not know that
it's very common in computer chess games
to play from a book and play a position
that's often considered balanced but
very complex where there's a good chance
of decisive games you basically don't
want the engines to play the berlin all
the time
in this game this is where the book
stops so all of these moves were
compelled for the chess engine they
don't necessarily consider them best but
they consider this position interesting
and now here we get bishop b5 the first
move selected by an engine now we get
bishop d6 and f4 trying to rip open the
long diagonal here of course you cannot
capture because a bishop takes g7 and
the rook is trapped in the corner
after f4 black plays pawn to f6 trying
to keep a really solid center here as
white trying to bring pressure against
that center
and now queen two h5 check inducing pawn
to g6 which softens that long diagonal a
little bit
queen h4 and black captures on f4 e
takes f4
now we get the first sacrificial
decision from stuffles in this game here
if pawn takes f4 might certainly not
losing but this is a bit to black's
advantage queen e7 check and you're
induced here to play knight e2 and the
knights not super happy on e2 black is
better able to utilize the e-file and
black seems to be a little bit better
and that little bit matters to chess
engines
so
instead stoffles prioritizes development
activity open lines and plays knight to
f3 a very interesting probably quite
strong move both engines basically
consider this
very complex and pretty unclear at this
point pretty balanced but by no means
drawn
so here we get f takes e3 which might be
a little bit too greedy but okay
and another pawn sacrifice castles
determined not to recapture the pawn on
e3 if at all possible
here if black gets extra greedy and
keeps trying to capture pawns the black
basically just loses on the spot this is
a really bad move and now after knight
takes d2 here black is actually busted
all of white's pieces are developed
white's castled the rook is coming over
here to the e file and if for example
bishop d7 you just have rookie one check
king f7 and c4 is a really strong move
this is going to rip open these lines
here and black's king
is just getting
just slaughtered on all of these
diagonals
so after castles black chooses to
develop bishop to d7 white continues to
prioritize piece activity knight c3 here
knight c to e7 going for an exchange and
a release of pressure here along this
line
and now white says okay it's finally
time i will recapture the pawn pawn
takes on e3
c6 pushing the bishop back and the
bishop falls back to d3 queen c7 and e4
rawr trying to open lines in the middle
of the board white has committed to
being upon down and wants the maximum
open lines so that these well-placed
pieces you know can bring pressure
against the opponent's position
black castle's queen side here
opposite sides castling is always really
really exciting in this position
it looks like it might be
kind of unclear
both players could have uh you know
chances to attack but it seems to
actually be in white's favor
and i think the reason turns out to be
that white has a good way to open lines
on the queen side by pushing the a and b
pawns up the board which is what happens
in the game and black's not really in a
position to push these pawns very
effectively when you have an opposite
side's castling position pushing pawns
to open lines is super critical and i
think this bishop being placed right
here and the inability to move the
knight on g8 makes it very very hard for
black to advance on the king side
we get pawn takes d5 c takes d5 and now
a real computer move i love this one
king h1 i'm going to go ahead and throw
a brilliant on this move even though i
don't completely understand it i think
this move is basically saying hey what
are you going to do
you don't really have any good moves for
black
and by playing king h1 i avoid some
checks from the queen or the bishop at
some point
where
you know some tactics might not work out
for me because of these checks so
i don't necessarily have the best
improving moves at my disposal at the
moment you have no good dis
improving moves at your disposal so i'm
just going to play king h1 and ask you
what you're going to do
well the engine plays pawn 2 h5 which
looks nice
but again it turns out to be very hard
to advance at open lines on the king
side
a4 by the way at this point igel is
saying that this is negative one that
basically igel thinks it's up upon for
nothing here whereas stuffles thinks
that it's about equal here and likes its
compensation for the pawn
pawn to a6
trying to take control of the b5 square
which isn't really going to work out now
pawn to b4 the queen is defending here
on this
long rank so the bishop cannot capture
on b4
and in this position the best move
according to stuff lays was knight 2h6
just trying to develop that knight and
really improve the coordination
of all of the pieces and it still thinks
this is really quite unclear
instead
black pushes forward with the pawns pawn
g5 gaining a tempo on the queen and
playing to win the b4 pawn but this
proves to be way too greedy
queen back to f2 the queen is pushed
away from the defense of the b4 pawn
and we now see igel capture that which
is
very greedy igel demonstrates a lot of
greediness in this game and is punished
for it
now how is igel going to be punished
well it is the spectacular move
knight 2 b5
a brilliant first piece sacrifice
and at this point stoffle's is basically
sacrificing the knight
just to open the a file it's not like a
human sacrifice where you sacrifice and
you just immediately get checkmate or
get your material back it's just saying
hey i don't need the knight so much but
i do need the open a file and it may
take me 20 moves but i'm going to make
that a file count
after knight b5 stopless says that this
is plus 1.12
so a clear advantage for white white is
bordering on winning in engine parlance
after knight b5 we see pawn takes b5 by
the way igel thinks it's totally okay
and thinks it's better pawn takes b5 and
now because of the idea of rook up to a8
which would win the queen b6 is
basically forced in this position now
rook a6 actually other rook lifts were
also good you basically just want to
play
to bring the other rook over and invade
on the a file successfully so rook a6
and now king to b7 here
and bishop to d4 attacking b6 which is a
very soft point in the position
now
in this position there are two ways that
i can really see to defend the b6 pawn
one is knight c8 which is played in the
game and the other is bishop c5 which
actually will come up
in a moment let's see
so
after knight c8
here we see pawn c3
and now the bishop needs to decide where
to fall back to
if it goes to c5 we basically get a
transposition to if black had played
bishop c5 instead of knight c8 a moment
ago
now after bishop c5 here
this is
getting close to like zug's wing for
black in terms of just not being able to
release any of the pressure here and we
just play rook fa1
and the idea is to play queen a2
rook up to a8 and then queen in to a7
and that's just going to be checkmate
and it turns out that even if this idea
is slow
there's really no good way for black to
stop this idea crushing idea invasion on
that a file that we sacrificed the
knight to open
so
backing up
after c3 black decides on bishop a5
which also looks very sensible just
because we're trying to close the a file
and say hey you can double rooks but
i've clogged the a file you're not going
to get in
i'm doing totally okay
so at this point stophles opens more
lines pawn to c4 trying to get this
light squared diagonal open which would
be very very appealing
g4 attacking the knight and rook takes
a5 here another brilliant sacrifice in
fact
offering two sacrifices here the rook
for the bishop and leaving the knight
hanging on f3
now you need to capture the more
important piece capturing the knight
just doesn't work here
um in this position now you move the
work off of a5 and you actually want to
make the unintuitive human move and pull
the rook all the way back to a1 you know
you'd be thinking i want a double rooks
why would i want to pull the rook all
the way back
but the key is in many cases where
you're invading on a file you want to
lead with your queen so you pull the
rook all the way back and now queen a2
is basically just a crushing idea
and there's no way to defend capturing
on g2 just doesn't change anything the
king is still totally safe and you still
have the basic winning idea
so after rook takes a5 we do see the
capture of the rook and white is now
down a rook in this position
and at least to a human it doesn't look
like there are any clearly obvious
threats but black is just not going to
be able to defend on the queen side
b6 gaining a tempo on the queen
queen to d6 c5 gaining another tempo and
opening critical lines here to attack
at this point stuff liz is saying this
is plus 1.26 a really big advantage for
white and igel says this is negative
3.07
black is basically winning igel is not
correct evidently
now uh the queen moves over to c6 knight
d2 with an idea of knight b3 and knight
into a5 which is very scary which is why
black plays the only move that black can
really try here a4
and now probably the prettiest move in
the game night b
three
beautiful
beautiful beautiful beautiful move the
night is sacrificed the idea of night
day five means that the night must be
accepted but cannot allow the knight to
come into a5 but capture of the knight
does mean that the a file is open rook
a1 black is now up a minor piece and a
rook and it just doesn't matter black is
getting crushed over here on the a file
and the king is just so claustrophobic
with all of these pawns
around it obviously in this position
bishop a6 is just a devastating idea on
the spot
black needs to give back some material
to get some escape squares for the king
so knight to d6
rook a7 checked before capture of the
knight king b8 and now you do capture
the knight white is down white is back
to only being down one rook in this
position queen c1 check and i have to
admit if i were playing white i'd be
very concerned about this check like in
this position you obviously can't trade
queen so to block the check you must
play bishop f1 and as a human without
the ability to calculate nearly as far
as a chess engine i would be worried
about the b pawn about the back rank and
saying hey can i actually make any
progress in this position
when i'm trying to finish off the attack
but only my rook is really up in the
black king's business at this point
and
i have all these problems to deal with
well the answer is yes you can continue
the attack
black plays knight to h6
queen to e2 intending queen to a6 when
the queen both serves the checkmating
ideas and defends the back rank over
here so white's attack is there in time
queen back to c6 queen to a6 here which
threatens
uh a number of things including queen a5
and then rook c7 getting the move order
right and ultimately white is trying to
arrange b7 uh without allowing a queen
trait obviously and then rook to a8
black plays b2
looking for counter play and i think
here's really where i joel is missing
the crushing idea in the position
because igel still thinks it's better
until the next move from uh from still
plays or i think it thinks it's equal at
this point
if bishop takes b2 then black has enough
time to bring the rook out
activate the rook and in this position
it's actually very unclear and the
engines both say 0.00
but
we don't capture the b2 pawn instead we
simply calmly play queen a2
and the idea is simply to play queen
takes b2
b7
and then rook a8 checkmate
and that idea turns out to basically be
unstoppable black is still up a rook but
black is going to have to have to give
up the queen to deal with all of these
threats so this queen a2 move
calmly
stopping the b-pawn and getting ready to
get the queen to the b-file by capturing
the pawn is really the decisive idea
so after queen a2 we see b1 queen
and uh we just capture that of course
the knight surges back knight f5
attacking the bishop and attacking the
pawn but we don't need to defend the
bishop we have b7 yet another p
sacrifice but this one trivially cannot
be accepted because of knight takes d4
rook a8 checkmate and this pawn on d6
covers that escape square
so
after b7 is it's critical not to go
after the bishop but to eliminate that
pawn that is controlling the escape
square knight takes d6
and now rook a6
basically the final critical point it
turns out
that the black queen is trapped on c6
she has
no safe squares the only square you
might look to
is queen back to c7 but then the queen
is blocking that escape square we were
just talking about so rook a8 is again
checkmate
so the only question after rook a6
is how does black choose to give up the
queen
if you try queen takes b7 there's rook
to b6
and you might be like okay i'm up so
much material i can let your rook
capture my queen and i'll be okay but
it's not just going to be the queen that
has won white has such a huge positional
advantage that white will have other
gains as well for example let's say
black plays bishop back to c8 to try to
hold on to the queen
you pile up with bishop a6 queen takes
b6 queen takes knight back to b7 and
bishop e3 is one very nice line the
bishop comes to this diagonal which
cannot be defended
and then you have the idea of bishop
takes knight and queen a5 this is just
crushing stuff there's no defense for
black the bishops and the queen work
together
beautifully
so after rook a6 black gives up the
queen with knight takes on b7
and now rook just takes queen bishop
takes and here black is still up
material right you've got two rooks and
two pawns for the queen which is very
nice but another final point bishop
takes f6
and it's clear that white is at least
getting back to material equality
because of the fork on the rooks
in this position but white is going to
get even more than that because white
has a huge positional advantage with the
safer king and the bishops our murder on
these open diagonals
king c7 now you could just capture the
exchange here and then try and invade
with your queen and you're close to
winning but your bishop is so strong you
don't need to go after the exchange yet
so you can just keep improving your
position king g1 is now played rook h6
bishop g5
choosing not to take the exchange and
instead keep the rooks forked which is
funny rook to d6 and now bishop f4 and i
find it funny that a moment ago we had a
bishop on f6 four king rooks on d8 and
h8 and now we have a bishop on f4 and
we've still forked the rooks and we've
added a pin so we've improved our
position because now we've added the pin
to our arsenal just keeping black bound
up rookie 6 queen a1 the queen is going
to get in on the queen side
or on the king side rookie 4 bishop to
g3 keeping the pin and not cashing in
yet rook a4 queen h8 this pawn is
falling
king b6 and finally white has a material
advantage in this position
ultimately here this position is winning
for white because we are going to create
a past h pawn
and we are just going to win the game
probably most resilient on a human level
is something like rookie 4 and white
needs to push forward and white should
win with the past h pawn the engines
agree and its engines playing so we're
going to trust that they know what
they're talking about in terms of this
instead we see knight c4 which i think
is less resilient from humans
human's perspective because now white
gets connected passers and it's much
easier to win in the computer chess
championship where this game was played
all games are played out till checkmate
but at this point the game is clearly
not in doubt at all the pawns just
surged forward the queen and king are
activated to their maximum
and eventually white picks off all the
material and mates in the end with the
king and queen
in this position
i hope you've enjoyed this game
incredible chess game really fascinating
to see the difference in agreement uh
the difference in assessment of the two
chess engines stuffless and uh igel and
just wonderful sacrifices all around
with knight b5 opening up the a file
rook takes a5 and ultimately that knight
b3 special special stuff i hope you've
enjoyed this game if you want to see
more of these incredible computer chess
games then check out that playlist that
is popping up on your screen
[Music]